-Oh, hi!
[ Laughing ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Alright, we're gonna play
a fun game!
Alright.
Now, get in your phone booths.
-Alright.
-Here is how we play the game.
-Shaq, you're going
to love this, man.
It's so fun.
You're gonna love this.
Yeah, you got...
-In here?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Alright.
That's perfect.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
The rules are simple.
When you get a question wrong,
a stranger
from the mystery bench
gets shoved into your booth.
[ Laughter ]
First question.
First question is for Hugh.
-Mm.
[ Telephone rings ]
Ah. Yeah? Hey.
-Hey, Hugh.
-Hey, how are you, man?
-It's Jimmy, man.
-Hey, Jimmy.
-Oh, sorry.
-What up?
-Hugh, Hugh, Hugh, Hugh.
-Thank you.
-Jackman.
Hugh, I have a question
for you, pal.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-What country
invented the sauna?
-The sauna? Mm.
Scandinavian, Scandinavian.
Finland? Finland.
-That is correct!
-Ohh!
-Hey!
-It's Finland.
-It is Finland.
-Whoo!
-Joining Shaq's booth...
-There's no way he got
that answer right.
You gave him the answers.
-...is long-time host
of "Jeopardy!"
He's the best in the business.
Who is Alex Trebek?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You ever met Shaq before?
Step on in.
♪♪
-Do we have to close the door?
-Good to see you, buddy.
-Yes. It really is.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
[ Applause ]
-Okay. Okay. This next...
-Something's pressing
against my chest.
I hope it's his belly button.
-No, it is.
That is his belly button.
He has an outie.
-Alright.
-Next question is for Shaq.
-Come on, Shaq.
[ Telephone rings ]
-You got to pick up the...
-"Chello"?
-Hey, Shaq.
Good to see you, man.
Good to hear you.
Good -- Whatever.
It's Jimmy calling.
-What's up, bro?
-Everything's great, my friend.
Shaq, what is
the longest bone --
what is the longest bone
in the human body?
-Femur.
-The femur.
-That is correct!
The femur is right!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
-Joining Hugh Jackman, from the
world-renowned Blue Man Group,
a Blue Man!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
You can get right in there,
Blue Man.
Get in there with Hugh Jackman.
♪♪
Yeah. Fantastic. There's Hugh.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, man. How are you?
-Hugh and...
-Good to see you. You good?
-He looks scared.
He looks frightened.
He looks -- He looks scared.
Everything's okay.
Everything's alright.
-Okay. We're good.
-Our next question...
-We're good.
-You're looking at me
so disappointed, Alex.
You're looking at me like,
"This is a game show?"
Yeah, it is.
Alex. This next question
is for Hugh.
-Yeah.
[ Telephone rings ]
-Buddy. It's Jimmy again.
-Yes. Hello.
-Sorry, man.
My Google is broken.
Can you answer a question?
-Yeah.
-What is the largest planet
in our solar system?
-Jupiter.
-That is correct!
Jupiter is right!
-Ohh!
♪♪
Joining Shaq's booth,
from NBC's hit show
"The Blacklist,"
the lovely Megan Boone,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
There you go. That's Shaq.
That's Alex Trebek.
-Saturn. Saturn.
Jimmy, I think Saturn.
It was Saturn.
-I'm so glad you got that.
-Yeah. You guys
are kind of psyched
that he got that one right.
-Yeah.
-Alright.
Here we go. Very good.
Megan Boone, Alex Trebek, Shaq.
Very good.
-I'm trying to keep
my hands away from Shaq.
-No, no, Alex.
Everything's fine.
Shaq. Alright.
Shaq, I have
a question for Shaq.
[ Telephone rings ]
-What up, boy-boy?
-It's me. It's boy-boy.
Uh...
Shaq, name all the Spice girls
by their nicknames.
-Ohh.
-Megan, help him out.
-I need help.
-There's Ginger.
-Ginger Spice.
-Yes.
-Sporty Spice.
-Yep.
-Scary Spice.
-Yeah.
-Two more.
-I'm embarrassed.
-Oh, sorry.
You forgot Posh and Baby Spice.
-Ugh!
-Sorry. You were wrong.
So now we have to add
one more person
from the mystery bench...
-Geez.
-...into Shaq's booth.
His show "Knife Fight" returns
for a fourth season
on November 10th
to the Esquire Network.
Make some noise for Chef
Ilan Hall, ladies and gentlemen.
Good to see you, buddy.
-How are you?
-Great.
That's Shaq.
That's Megan Boone.
That's Alex Trebek.
You can get in there, Ilan.
You might just -- You get there.
You know Shaq.
-Hey, Shaq.
-Oh, there we go.
-Alright. Hey, guys.
-Hey.
-Perfect.
-Aah!
-Hey.
-Alright.
-Wow.
-Alright. Perfect. Okay.
This is good.
Something just broke.
[ Busy signal ]
Oh, guys!
You know what that means.
It's time for the final call.
-Final call.
-We're just relaxing, chilling.
-Are you guys
getting along well?
-We're getting on
really well now.
He's a great guy.
-I feel comfortable here.
-We're flowing here.
It's flowing.
-Winner of this ne--
He wrote "help" on the glass.
[ Laughs ] Oh, my God.
Winner of this next question
gets to shove everyone else
from their mystery bench
into their opponent's booth.
Let's bring out everyone
from the mystery bench.
The hosts of HGTV's
"Property Brothers,"
Jonathan and Drew Scott!
♪♪
-Hey.
-Good to see you, buddy.
-Thank you, man. Thank you.
-And from your 2015
National League East Division
champion New York Mets,
it is Mr. Met,
ladies and gentlemen!
♪♪
Great to see you, buddy.
Oh, come on.
Great to see you.
Congrats on everything.
Alright. Now, the final
question is for Hugh.
-Ohh.
-Hugh Jackman.
[ Telephone rings ]
-Yeah.
-Hey, man. It's Jimmy again.
-What building is on the back
of a $20 bill?
♪♪
-What building is on the back
of a $20 bill?
-He doesn't talk.
[ Laughter ]
-"Help."
The Australian $20 bill?
-It's not the Australian one.
Yeah.
-White House?
-It is the White House!
Get in there.
Have you met Shaq, Megan Boone?
Yeah, yeah.
Have you met these guys?
-Blue Man, Blue Man.
Congratulations, you guys.
That means Hugh Jackman
is the winner.
-I think that's as good
as I can do.
-There you go right there.
Fantastic.
Our thanks to Hugh Jackman,
Shaquille O'Neal, Alex Trebek,
the Blue Man Group,
Megan Boone, Chef Ilan Hall,
Jonathan and Drew Scott,
Mr. Met!
Thank you for playing. The rules
of this game are very simple.
I'll be asking you both
trivia questions.
If you get a question wrong,
a stranger from
our mystery bench
gets shoved into
your phone booth.
[ Laughter ]
The first question
is for Hailey.
[ Telephone ringing ]
-Hello.
-Hey, what's up? It's Jimmy.
-Hey. How are you?
-How you doing?
-Good.
-Cool.
Hailey?
-Yes.
-Name three actors
who played James Bond.
-Daniel Craig.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-Pierce Brosnan?
-That's correct.
-And --
Oh, man.
[ Slide whistle ]
Daniel Craig.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I'm sorry,
Daniel Craig is only one person.
Hailey, you lost, which means
joining your booth,
from the world-famous
Harlem Globetrotters,
currently playing in the 2020
"Pushing the Limits World Tour,"
give it up for Jet Rivers!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, come on, dude.
You know what's --
Oh! Come on, now.
[ Laughing ] Oh!
Come on, bud.
Good to see you, buddy.
You know Hailey?
♪♪
-I'm gonna bring this
in here with you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Next question --
The next question is for Norman.
[ Telephone ringing ]
-Hello?
-How you doing, bud?
-Hey.
-Hey, I have a question for you.
What brass instrument
was once known as the sackbut?
-The what?
-The sackbut.
♪♪
The sackbut.
-Saxophone?
-That is incorrect.
I'm so sorry.
It was the trombone
is the correct answer.
-That makes no sense.
-Joining Norman's booth,
they've got one thing
on the brain, and it is brains,
it's "The Walking Dead" zombies.
Oh, my --
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's hilarious.
-Oh, my goodness. Oh!
-[ Yelling ]
-Oh, my -- Oh, they're coming.
Oh, my gosh. Be careful!
Oh. It's getting cramped.
-That's a regular day for you.
-It's getting cramped in there.
Be sure --
Make sure you close the door.
Absolutely right.
Alright.
-Hi, guys.
-[ Growls ]
-Our next question
is for Hailey.
[ Telephone ringing ]
-Hello?
-Hey, it's Jimbo.
-Hey.
-Hailey, Justin Bieber has had
several Billboard Hot 100
#1 hit songs.
-Mm-hmm.
-Name three of them.
-"Sorry."
-Uh-huh.
-"What Do You Mean?"
-Yes.
-"Baby."
-No.
-"Sorry," "What Do You Mean?"
and --
and "Where Are U Now."
-No.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer, foghorn ]
-They're cheating. You cheated.
-The answers were, "Sorry,"
"Love Yourself,"
"What Do You Mean?"
"I'm the One," or "Despacito."
-Right --
Oh, right!
-She said that.
-I forgot that!
-Joining Hailey's booth,
from American polka band
Don't Polka the Bear,
it's accordionist Derek Franz!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
[ Accordion playing ]
[ Accordion plays off-key ]
-Hey! Hello!
-Hi.
Welcome.
[ Accordion plays ]
-Our next question
is for Norman.
[ Telephone ringing ]
-[ Grunts ]
-That doesn't sound like Norman.
-[ Growling, panting ]
-Alright, Norman?
Norman, you got this one.
How many letters are in the name
Benedict Cumberbatch?
-Oh, man.
-He can't count.
[ Growling ]
-[ Groaning ]
-Don't -- No hints.
-19.
19?
-That is correct!
The answer is 19!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aw, yeah.
-Joining Hailey's --
Joining Hailey's booth,
from Ontario, Canada,
it's the world's oldest
Justin Bieber impersonator.
[ Laughter ]
-Yummy, yummy, yummy.
-Yummy, yummy, that's right.
Just go --
Justin --
-That one?
-Justin, this way.
Yep. There you go.
[ Laughter ]
Yummy, yummy, yummy.
[ Accordion playing off-key ]
That's right.
Alright, very good.
Yummy, yummy, yummy, very good.
[ Laughter ]
-How do I answer the phone?
-Alright, here we go. This is
the final call right here,
as we know by this sound effect.
[ Disconnected phone beeping ]
Thank you.
Hailey? Hailey?
-Yes?
[ Telephone ringing ]
Hey, Jimmy.
-Hey, what's up?
How did you know --
How did you know it was me?
-I just took a wild guess.
[ Laughter ]
-Hailey, which one of these
balls weighs the most --
football, basketball,
or soccer ball?
♪♪
-Basketball.
-Is that your final answer?
-That's my final answer.
-You are correct!
[ Ding! ]
-Because I had it in here!
-Come on.
-The winner of this question
gets to shove everyone else
from the mystery bench
into their opponent's booth.
You are the winner.
Let's bring out the bench,
First, you know her.
You love her.
She stars in Bravo's hit
reality show, "Below Deck,"
my favorite, give it up for
everyone's favorite chief stew,
Kate Chastain!
-Hi. Nice to see you.
-Come on, pal. I love you.
-Thanks. I go over here?
-Yeah, go on in.
Say hi to Norman. Norman's --
-Come on in.
-Hey!
-Some zombies.
-Guys, you can head over there
if you want.
Next, the Instagram sensation
who needs no introduction,
it's Dude with Sign.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Am I getting out?
-You can get in there, too.
And finally,
from Syracuse University,
Otto the Orange, everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nice to see you, Otto.
Get on in there.
That's perfect right there.
Our thanks to Norman Reedus,
Hailey Bieber,
Kate Chastain, Jet Rivers,
the Harlem Globetrotters,
Dude with Sign,
and Syracuse University!